we have an update on a Texas student
whose high school told him he would not
be allowed to walk at graduation unless
he cuts his dreadlocks we first brought
you deandre Arnold's story last week
since then he's received a wave of
support last night we surprised him with
another big opportunity from some famous
faces take a look
hey DeAndre I'm Gabrielle Union and I am
one of the producers of the
oscar-nominated animated short film hair
love what's up DeAndre man you and your
mother sandy artificial guests of the
Oscar nominated team behind hair love at
the 2020 Academy of movies we've all
been so inspired by your story and this
is the very least we can do to thank you
for standing up for yourself and for
your right to wear your natural hair in
school that was director Matthew a
cherry who was here yesterday along with
Dwyane Wade and Gabrielle Union DeAndre
and his mom are flying to LA to hit the
red carpet as Cherry's special guest at
the Academy Awards on February 9th his
film hair love is nominated for Best
Animated Short here's the Andres
reaction it's crazy like I never thought
that people like d-wade and Gabrielle
Union would be like on my side the film
is about hair love and me and my hair
kind of grew up together in a way it's
like we're best friends it really just
means so much that we get an invite like
this like it means the world does
honestly how exciting and he's gotten a
scholarship she's a lot of love and
support coming at him yeah Matthew told
us at the end of the show yesterday they
really wanted to do this it's a really
great gesture so the honor resolved
issue of walking at graduation together
is